*sighs*
This is just the kind of video...
where you need a little bit of the... (alcohal)
*sniffs*
Support.
*pours drink*
*sniffs again*
*slurps*
"I SHALL CONSUME YOUR SOUL"
(i have no idea what the fuck ainsley is saying.)
"COMING SOON."
"IT WILL BEGIN SOON."
"YOU WILL ALL PERISH."
*boing*
Ah.
It's time.
I found the worst cringe related to PewDiePie.
And I'm gonna react to it.
I might not make it out alive!
We just gonna have to see.
"Name:"
huh
"Darkedgebloodsword"
That is already the coolest name
I've ever heard.
"Weapon: Soul Katana"
Dude
*silence*
You had a darkedgebloodsword,
but your weapon is a Soul Katana!
NOW YOU'RE JUST BEING RIDICULOUS!
*I SHALL FIND (WHAT ARE YOU SAYING DEAR LORD)*
"Favorite movie: The Dark Knight"
you're a sonic fan characther what do u know your real name could be cinos
Of course.
"Darkedgebloodsword the hedgehog hate-"
*laughs* The hedgehog.
Excuse me!
Is Darkedgebloodsword here?
No?
The hedgehog?
Oh! Right there.
Okay, cool.
*laughs*
His friends are Shaggy 2Dope,
Shrek and PewDiePie.
Thank you.
Darkedgebloodsword my- my good old friend.
My good old pal.
"My heart is a black tormented hole of emptiness."
"How are you?"
*cringe*
DO NOT STEAL...
DARKEDGEBLOODSWORD.
DO NOT FUCKING STEAL
DARKEDGEBLOODSWORD'S MATERIAL BIO!
(DON'T YOU DARE STEAL HIS MATERIAL BIO)
It says 'Slipknot' on his hat
that's awesome, dude.
*MORE INAUDIBLE*
I SHALL RISE
"PewDiePie haircut"
*dramatic music*
Fuck sake, man.
It's the same when like people get my-
I've noticed people getting my tattoos and stuff.
And it's just like- why?
Wha-??
*disappointed pewds*
*sad music*
So this is a Facebook post,
Dumb pewdiepie fans are tricked (pewdiepie fans are dumb)
"into burning themselves"
"#Burn4Pewds I love you, Felix"
"you were always there for me"
"and now I'm gonna be here for you."
when you die
I don't know what's more cringe-
This post? Or the fact that people think
it's real?
Honestly, it's so obviously fake.
You- you just look up someone that burn-
Okay. Y'know what?
See if I can find that same image.
Oh, wow. there's the image, how bout dat (how did you find that)
It's from Afghanistan.
I guess I have fans in Afghanistan.
I don't know, man.
What do you think about-
What do you think about that, Ainsley?
*ONE DAY SOON*
*I WILL CONSUME*
*YOUR*
*SOUL*
I agree 100% with what he just... said. (why)
Pitbull!
"Hey PewDiePie love your videos and"
*more silence*
"and" WHAT PITBULL?!
*Windows' music*
the left eye illumanati cunfurmed
Oh my god.
Now this is some cringe.
Prepare yourself.
This was when I lived in Italy,
and some guy, that was on holiday in Italy,
came by our house.
My girlfriend's mom opened the door and was like
"There's a fan out there, you have to go."
And I was like,
"Okay :v"
You know why it said "After some waiting"?
Because I didn't wanna fucking go out.
I was like, "This is crazy."
"What the fuck are they doing here?"
Don't get me wrong.
If I meet you anywhere else,
Literally anywhere else,
we can be taking a piss.
On a urinal. (noice)
I'll be fine meeting you.
But,
don't come to my house.
It's so wrong!
Oh my God this is long ago.
This is very long ago.
2013.
"Um.. sup."
*dog barking*
OH MY GOD, I'M WEARING THE PEWDIEPIE SHIRT! *laughs*
"Very nice to meet you."
"Nice meeting you too, Shhhh."
Back then... everything was so new.
And this was the first time this happened to me.
I didn't know how to... react. (well when you meet a stranger you gotta punch them in the face)
That's why this video is so cringy, dude.
"-channel. And I created a video asking the bros to-"
"put a comment, to ask you some questions, but"
"nobody commented.... So."
"Really?"
"Yeah.. and..."
"That sucks."
"Yeah, that...that sucks."
(dat is the face of fuckin regret and cringe, everybody.)
He was gonna interview me, but he was...
really bad at interviewing. (#rekt)
"Seventh- second question." (dear god)
"Ye?"
"Um-"
Oh, you can tell how fucking tired I am here, dude.
"Secon - second question."
"Ye?"
"Um-"
Look at how fucking done I am!
"Uh- yeh."
"Um.. I..."
"I still...get - I still.. ugh!" (your stuttering poods)
"I guess I still can't answer the question, obviously."
"Ye?"
Aghhhh.
I sweating now. This is legit cringing me out, man.
Oh, this is a good one!
"Awkwardly handshake executed by"
"Conan O'Brien and PewDiePie and some middle aged man."
"Hold the left trigger! There you go!"
*screams of victory*
"OH YEAAHH!"
"YES!"
"Got 'em!"
"That was very exci- that was awful."
"It started to-"
*LET THE CRINGE FEST BEGIN*
(i'm so... speechless.)
(there's that face again.)
*sad violin music*
(i'm fuckin cringing here this is so bad i can't)
My face is just like, "oh god."
"this is gonna be on the internet forever now."
Great.
"Ye?"
See, this is why!
You should never do a handshake!
And anything's that's being recorded,
that you can't control!
"You better go~"
"Never let go, go, go~" (let it go plez)
"Never give up, up, up~"
"Never let go, never give up!~"
"You let go, you asshole~" *dabs*
Hmmmmmm-
Don't-
Don't~
*slurp*
I never asked for this, you know..
I never asked for this.
"Oh! I was- hah!"
"I was just reading some YouTube comments."
"Oh, look!"
"There's one right in here!"
"PEWDIEPIE SUCKS!"
*overly dramatic gasp*
"PEWDIEPIE IS GAYYY!"
*rubs and pinches nips* "What do I do to make people"
"think I'm gay?"
(noice pewds.)
"I really don't get it!"
I can't-
I can't.
Old PewDiePie videos..I can't.
Alright?
I'm not touching that shit.
That's in the PAST!
I can't- no.
Anything but old PewDiePie videos!
They're the fucking worse!
Ugh!
Shoo!
Shoo, old PewDiePie videos!
AINSLEY, DO SOMETHING!
*shakes ainsley*
DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE VIDEOS!!
I STILL GET AD REVENUE FROM THEM- (oops)
(c'mon sing with me)
~ Why can't we be friends, why can't we be ~
Okay.
That's enough cringe.
Can we all just take a moment and support...
With all these cringy PewDiePie videos and images,
I don't know how much longer I'm-
I'm gonna make it, alright?
Let's make it happen!
Let's make that shit trend!
That's it for me now, though!
*breathes*
Leave a like if you enjoyed watching!
And as always!
I'll see you bros *smooch* tomorrow with another video!
Stay awesome, bros!
so he cunfurms it (some of dis was edited by ian uh mention me lol)
(alah ahkbar)